임대료가 넘어요. 전 꺾이지 않은
그거였는데 대로를 넘는게 진짜 쉽지
않거든요. [음악] 깜짝깜짝
놀랍니다. 네. 안녕하세요. 오늘
주제는 성수를 살까요? 아니면 강남을
살까요로라는 주제로 [음악] 촬영을
할 예정인데이 질문을 고객분들한테
굉장히 좀 많이 듣습니다. 그래서
오늘 제가이 영상으로 정확한 답을 좀
드리도록 하겠습니다. 우선 성수라고
하면은 성수 전체를 얘기하는게
[음악] 아니라 저는 연무장길을 좀
주로 얘기하거든요. 그래서 지금
연무장길은 서울시 그 어떤 상권 가장
핫하고 지금 매매 가격뿐만 아니라
임대교로 굉장히 가파르게 오르는
곳입니다. 최근에 저번 주만 해도
지금 한 세 건 정도 했고 그리고
작년 같은 경우에는 저희가 성수동
거래 건수가 정말 강남이랑 비슷하게
거래가 됐습니다. 그중에 연무장길
거래가 가장 많이 됐습니다. [음악]
그래서 지금 연무장길 거래 가격
보면은 뭐 3억은 이미 진작
뛰어넘었고 지금 거의 5억을 향해서
가고 있고 매매 나온 거 중에서는
거의 6억, 7억 그 이상에도 나와
있습니다. 그리고 임대료 같은
경우에는 저는 진짜 [음악] 마칠
때마다 깜짝깜짝 놀랍니다. 뭐
연면적이 막 진짜 40평, 50평
정도인데도 불구하고 [음악]
임대료가 1억이 넘어요. 임대료가
거의 명동을 뛰어 넘었습니다. 네.
아무래도 임대료가 높다 보니까 매매
가격도 계속 [음악] 오르고 있어요.
그러니까 임대료가 받쳐주고 있거든요.
사실 지금 강남 같은 경우에는 임대료
상황이 그렇게 좋지 않습니다.
[음악] 그래서 임대료 수준도 그렇게
많이 오르고 있지 않아요. 제가 진짜
강남 찬양용자인데도 불구하고 저 진짜
강남을 매번 추천했잖아요. [음악]
전 꺾이지 않은 그거였는데 강남이
지금 안 좋다. 엄청 가격이
떨어진다. 그런게 아니라 지금 서울시
전체 대한민국 전체적으로 봤을 때
연무장끼리 [음악]
지금 월등이 좋습니다. 진짜 건물만
비어주면 들어오겠다라는 업체들이
[음악] 진짜 줄서 있습니다. 그래서
그 정도로 지금 연무장끼이 워낙
상황이 좋기 때문에 만약에 두 개
지역을 고민하신다라고 하면 저는
과감하게 연무장기를 투자하라고 좀
권하고 싶습니다. [음악]
지금 국내 사람들뿐만 아니라 외국인
관광객이 더 많거든요. 그래서 저희가
어깨 최초로 거기서 팝업 스토어를 해
봤는데 부동산 회사인데도 불구하고
3일 만에 거의 3,명 가까이
왔어요. 그래서 그 정도로 기업
[음악] 입장에서는 여기에 진짜 뭐
몇억을 투자하고도 충분히 들어올 만한
입지기 [음악] 때문에 비싼 임대료
주고 많이 들어오거든요. 뭐 북성수나
아니면은 다른 성수는 어떠냐는 또
질문들이 [음악] 많은데 저는
연무장길만 좀 설명드리고 싶어요. 어
북성수는 아직까지 상권이 거기
확장되기까지가 시간이 좀 많이 오래
걸릴 것 같고 그리고 어찌됐든 대로를
넘는게 진짜 쉽지 않거든요. 저는
연무장끼리나 북성수는 조금 다른
관점에서 좀 [음악] 보시는게 되게
중요하다라고 생각합니다. 같은 성수긴
하지만 진짜 번지수가 다른 곳이에요.
강남도 [음악] 비슷해요. 뭐 강남도
다 좋은게 아니라 강남 지역 내에서도
잘되는 동네들이 있고 임배가 잘
들어오는 그런 동네들이 있는 것처럼
성수도 그 연무장길
>> [음악]
>> 쪼개만 어 워낙 투자 가치가 높다라고
생각을 하기 때문에 그 연무장길
위주로 건물을 보시면 좋을 [음악]
것 같습니다. 진짜 임대 수익률이
저희도 막 마치고 보면은 뭐 3,
4% 이게 아니라 막 5%, 6%,
7% 막 그 이상도 하거든요.
그러니까 임대가 꺾이거나 아니면
매매가 좀 이렇게 꺾이는 그런 느낌이
있어야 되는데 지금 상황으로 봤을
때는 임대료가 워낙 높기 때문에
[음악] 계속 고객들도 많이 찾고
있거든요. 향후 막 이게 1, 2년
안에 꺾이거나 진짜 5년 안에 막
단기간에 엄청 꺾이거나 그럴 거 같진
않습니다. 소장에서 개인 사업을 하는
것보다 커브에 하는게 조금 더 이득이
>> 그니까 쉽게 설명드리면 연무장길은
그냥 내 건물을 광고판이라고
생각하시면 돼요. 근데 거기다가 뭐
사업을 하거나 이런 거는 수익성이
매우 [음악] 낮을 겁니다. 그래서
좋은 입지에 있는 어떻게 보면 광고판
건물을 잘 사 가지고 기업하게 임대
주는게 [음악] 훨씬 저는 이득이라고
생각을 합니다.
>> 근데 팝업하는 것부터 보면 기간이
정해져. 요즘에는 근데 팝업보다 그냥
장기 임대로 많이 들어오는 거
같아요. 물론 이제 팝업 해 가지고
뭐 단기간에 [음악] 수익성이 더
높아지긴 하는데 오히려 좀 요즘
기업들은 워낙 들어가기가 어려우니까
어 장기 임대로 좀 많이 들어오는 거
같습니다. 진짜 유명한 업체에서도
연락이 많이 왔거든요. 거기 대기업
임원분들이 막 연락 와가지고 찾아와서
제발 들어가고 싶다. 뭐 이런 문의가
올 정도로 기업들이 연무장길에 관심이
되게 많은 거 같아요. 요즘에 사실
TV 안 보잖아요. 기업들이 원래
이제 TV 광고로 비용을 좀 많이
썼거든요. 근데 사실 이렇게
연무장길, 외국인 관광객들이 많은
[음악] 그런 곳에 좀 잘 보이는
곳에 진짜 이렇게 광고비 쓴다
생각하면은 오히려 더 저렴하기도
합니다. 그래서 좀 그런 비용들
때문에 쓰는 거 같고이 성수동
자체가이 중공업 [음악]
지역이에요. 그래서 땅의 활용도도
굉장히 높고 전에 이제 공장으로 쓰다
보니까 땅의 면적이 큽니다. 그래서
기업들이이 땅을 활용하기가 [음악]
되게 좋아요. 그래서 진짜 큰 공장에
팝업을 열 수도 있고 땅 면적
사이즈도 [음악] 좋기 때문에 그런
점들 때문에 그 성수동이 다른
상권들과 좀 차별화가 있지 않나 어
이렇게 생각을 합니다.
하려고 하면은 자본이 어느 정도 올네
>> 지금 사실 연모장길 워낙 가격이 많이
올라서 금액들도 되게 높거든요.
그래서 일반 개인이 들어가기에는
[음악] 쉽지는 않습니다. 근데
연무장길의 좀 인접한 길를 접하고
있는 그런 [음악] 빌딩들은 아직까지
그래도 좀 투자할 만한 것들이 있기
때문에 그런 길들을 좀 유심히 보시면
[음악] 좋을 거 같아요. 예를
들어서 가로 스킬 같은 경우에는 물론
지금 상황이 안 좋아졌지만 가로
스킬이 이제 포화되다 보니까 거기
인근의 세로 스킬이라든지 [음악]
나로 스킬이 생긴 것처럼 연무장길도
지금 포화 상태긴 한데 거기 인근에
같이 좀 도로 잘 접해 있는 그런
건물들을 [음악] 찾으시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 그런 건물들이 궁금하시다면
언제든지 회사로 연락 주시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다.